hello and welcome to the new worlds
review where everything is flying off
the shelves that's right we are selling
every single opinionated word we have
for the low low price of your time give
us your time and your soul and we will
give you opinionated words you will
never regret some regret may occur it's
me grand line waifu here for episode 19
and 20 with fighting aplenty and wacky
inflatable armed men because sometimes
you just got to sell that non-existent
merch liam i need much to sell get on
that be nice everyone loves beanies put
the audio in a beanie but Hisoka in a
cool beanie put me in a cool beating
yeah beanies are the best if you two
like beanies click that thumbs up button
like a cool dude if you think beanies
are an awful idea you just don't have a
beanie but if you don't like what you're
seeing hit that thumbs down beanie
I mean button now the episode this
episode was fantastic I don't know how
else to begin this review I know that at
the top of my review for episode 17 and
18 I said I was bored but I knew it was
because we were on track for something
like this we had to put together the
setup of all the things we're starting
to see come to fruition it was funny and
tense and painful to watch and I really
appreciated everything about it from
finding out more about pretty boy Hanzo
to seeing lay audio and karateka get
genuinely angry to seeing kill I just
not get it let's zoom in on some of
these things a bit more because they
truly deserve it God not giving up was
entirely expected but I didn't expect
the series to get as specific and dark
while it did the last time we saw Khan
unwilling to give in it was with a his
Soaker punch in episode 16 we know that
he won't give in we know that he doesn't
want to give up and we know that he has
a score to settle with his soak up
there's no way he's going to allow that
to go unchecked we also watched what
looked like a grown man beating up a
child until Hanzo told dawn how old he
was and saw gongs reaction to that I did
think it was more heartless than it felt
afterward though it's still pretty
heartless it's rare by which I mean it's
not rare at all in anime and manga but
bear with me to see children so
deliberately beaten down on the point of
guns arm break I have to be honest and
say I didn't listen to it in very
childlike fashion I covered my ears
because the sound of breaking bones is
an emotional trigger I take it as gospel
that it happened and the way he held his
arm was enough for me the fact that
things got that dark at this early stage
in the final phase of the exam actually
gives me an odd form of hope for what
comes next
if they're not afraid to go to these
places now it gives a good sign that
they won't be concerned about going
further later on the issue of cutting
guns legs off it seems odd in retrospect
that a Hanzo didn't consider gone
bleeding out but it was hilarious
especially because there was so much
tension in the scene giving us that tiny
laugh was very much what we needed after
gone getting such a beating I knew
because he's in all the opening titles
and was the first character introduced
to us the gun wasn't going to fail or
die during the exam he's the one we've
been following from the get-go and it
this isn't Game of Thrones I do wonder
how everyone else's battles will go
given they can't just beat each other
until they give up it's a pretty neat
way of running a tournament very
Millennial as millennial I can totally
say that we're all winners except that
guy gone being an ass about winning is
so typical child and the angle of that
particular frame where Hans I was
looking down at him while he looks up
was so reminiscent every child I've ever
worked with that I almost threw my
computer across the room you know who
you are
there are times the art is perfectly on
point and this was one of them another
perfectly OnPoint moment was natera
saying no tequila it was unexpected and
tickled me in a way I simply don't
understand the comic timing involved he
was frankly wonderful and that's
something we haven't had for a little
while I feel verbal comic timing it's
been so physical Leo do Tonpa at arrow
even Hanzo they've been a physical
comedy in our comic relief I don't
include gone in this because he's our
anti protagonist he's required to be
able to engage in every genre
simultaneously the ups and downs of the
episode were potent and delicately
handled and I very much appreciated that
both emotionally and physically my body
reacted quickly and strongly in the
phrase emotional whiplash is the perfect
descriptor for this episode the boredom
of episode 17 was well balanced arc wise
with this episode that brings me back to
why I review each episode one by one as
I watch I want to see whether there are
any individual episodes that would make
me disconnect from the series and review
each episode individually for that
reason but I keep the entire arc in mind
too because that's something I can also
do so far the only episodes that might
have led me to disconnect was episode 17
because the energy was so disjointed
however by that point as an audience
member I've invested enough time in the
arc to think oh give the next couple of
episodes ago and find out what happens
to gone before I stop guess what
wrapping up that
detail led us to episode 19 got me
reengaged fully in the series and kept
me going with that in mind let's keep it
going with episode 20 goodness me we're
racing through episode 20 was good but
not as great as episode 19 while I
appreciate that God is the one we follow
and the one we're primarily interested
in I'm not a big fan of flashbacks
especially in the way it happened this
episode unfortunately the only thing
missing was the airwaves as we went back
to a time like it was yesterday
it actually was yesterday so I suppose
that helped I just wish we could have
had less in the way of congratulating
gone especially since they didn't go
into much more detail about what it
means to be a hunter in the information
we already had that information is still
pretty close to zero which make things
not confusing but they hunters can kill
as they please hunters can look for
things they're often varied in their
skill sets and they sometimes value and
do not value their action card it's very
odd that twenty episodes into a series
with double the amount of hunter in its
title compared to other shows we still
don't actually know how they're using
the word or whether it's the same twice
hunter squared hunters finding hunters
which when I think about it makes sense
forgone we can add that to the mix I'm
ready not to be so in the dark about
being a hunter while it's possible to
argue that we're learning along with
gone I think it would all be less of an
issue for me if God made note of the
fact that maybe he would learn what it
is to be a hunter now that he is one
given how many people we have and how
many different reasons they have for
wanting to be a hunter I don't
understand why the information about
what a hunter actually does has been
withheld like this the opening of the
anime itself has the outline of the idea
that people are drawn to explore the
unknown and find riches so they become
hunters this is all well and good but
they're taking a test to do it I want to
know what was happening in that
orientation and I don't want it to be
brushed over as inconsequential
information that's something I feel very
strongly about at this point at the end
of the episode we stepped into their
orientation which is truly the first
time and placed that maybe we could find
out why one needs to take a test to be a
hunter at all and whether there are any
actual responsibilities about being a
hunter beyond being an elite something
or other no let's put that aside
Kiowas brother let's discuss him for a
bit creepy guy who dug his way into the
ground only to emerge a beautiful
pinheaded boss
why people like he and his soca are good
examples of why a hunter exam seems like
a strange thing to me
anyone powerful enough or strong enough
can essentially become a hunter and that
leads to questions of why the
classification exists I'm hoping that
gets explained to us back to alumi we
knew that Kela came from a family of
assassins we knew that he was a child
assassin and that he had promised to see
him back down from a fight with someone
even a family member when we know that
he had almost killed his mother says
something about the training he received
the control alumi has over him is highly
disturbing and I both desperately want
to know and do not want to know at all
what the training of assassins entails
the moment to Lumi essentially tells
Kiawah he's broken and that he can never
have friends I felt a wave of empathy
for kill Wayne away I haven't before
here's a kid who's desperate to be like
other kids but instead is told that all
he can enjoy is killing we're all agreed
Illume is wrong right we saw here and
gone having fun just a few episodes ago
waiting for time to pass
we saw how he cared for gone and wanted
him to pass the exam even if the
question was whether he was struggling
to decide whether to kill God or not
we've seen them having fun together
the friendship they've grown over the
years I mean days has been important
it's been the only time we were able to
see gone and Kiowas the messed up
psychopathic children they are they play
they compete and they engage with each
other
Kilwa may be a killer but he's capable
of friendship in case you haven't
realized my maternal side is coming out
to play yes we have our two resident
Psychopaths but they are obviously child
psychopaths and nothing can change their
creepy friendship the moment of Kilwa
saying gone was going to pass the exam
because kill was said so was a huge
turning point for the character he made
clear the appreciation of his friend
illumi can go jump in a hole frankly
leave my boys alone with your creepy
swirl eyes and your pins of creepy
distortion it's the first time this
moment in fact that we see kill why
break out of his calm unwavering
observation even while Gahan was in his
final phase match killer didn't
understand it and got mad about the fact
that in his mind Hanzo just gave up kela
did not see the underlying emotional
impact Gahan could have on people killer
has much to learn about friendship and
about people and I'm excited to see what
becomes of this because the character
has so much mileage to be an assassin
you need to be able to turn
your empathy and do a job kela has been
able to do that for the most part but
the more he spent time we've gone the
more he's left a little empathy behind
to observe gone with and an assassin
with empathy is a dangerous thing
seeing Kilwa killed boudoir Oh seeing
killer killed the doral see him kill WA
kill someone this is unfair because I
know you're gonna edit this in this is
meme but I'm still gonna keep trying see
Inc you what kill beador Oh made me
wonder why he did it was it to gain
control over the situation in a way he
could or did he do it to help Leo do
pass the exam because that is what gone
would want was he trying to prove his
friendship to God in a time when he
didn't feel he could protect God it's
arguable that he just lost his mind and
reacted but I'm always searching for
meaning in behavior and I think that may
be it I look forward to finding out
whether I'm right but for now we're
going to wonder where he is
where is q1 hopefully we'll find out
next episode but for now this is it for
me if you enjoyed this video and please
do leave this video a like share or
subscribe and if you'd like to join the
fund and please do head over to the
discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan re takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on episodes 19 and 20 of
Hunter hunter this has been the new
worlds review and I'll see you next time